I'm a buff baby that contains like a man
I can shake it my fanny I could shake
them I can I forget that one line hey
can I try it can I join
no I think we've pretty much ruined the
video I'm gonna punch it your buns why
we broke up
wait broke Dugger and the book you're
welcome man had to be put in a book well
clearly since the people who memorize
the song still don't know what the song
you guys were like really excited to
you're like okay we have this dance
we're gonna so we're gonna get the
songbook I'm like there's a song your
bones
yet give more to the camera no yeah so
there's three trunks on the back oh
right you hold and she has the big eyes
you want yeah let's talk about the
episode because staying in this you yeah
so yeah memory of a memory they were
like really excited I thought it was
gonna be like okay well I'll give it a
lead-in so you got memory of a memory
you get a supposed spirit animal of
Marceline says that she put a sleep
spell on herself and that Finn and Jake
need to go inside her mind and get this
memory of when she did the sleep spell
like that yes
and they have to go in and so I'm
thinking like oh this is gonna be like
sensor big dream song or it's all gonna
be like a music or something it wouldn't
be this beeping production no it's just
there's a scene where Marceline goes in
Finn's mind and he's a baby and he just
does this dumb little dancers like John
there's no music to it there's no I know
it's a cappella problem a cappella no oh
okay for that much build-up yes I do
like a fella like a big group of people
coming together you know what I want
like if and when they do another season
of this I want adventure time to do like
this big orchestration of that song okay
just to make up for how much you guys
built it up cuz you guys really built it
up no no I want like John Williams
orchestrating this big thing of that
song just to make up for the build up
that you guys okay we're gonna do that
Jack
we hope sure Hey okay Jack's on it yeah
let me know how that goes
oh the Star Wars film composer not the
porn film composer why cuz I found out
actually there is I fell from Family Guy
a tree there so so okay so there's just
a lot you don't no idea how much
build-up that was for that but we're
probably going into too much detail all
right at least okay
so so so they go into her memory very
John Malkovich I beat John Malkovich
right to where they're like falling
through the doors and then like the
gravity changes and stuff like that and
they get to this memory and they grab
and it turns out it was actually her
boyfriend who was the spirit animal did
he actually have his arms a bit like do
you see they
beginning now okay I thought that
actually because I was thinking like
wait did I see his arms in the opening
and that when you saw he was just faking
it out I was like that'd be hilarious if
you actually saw that he had his arms
before and then said they did because I
don't know how many people would have
paid attention to that true like because
I was thinking like wait did he have his
arms or did he I think they actually
could have gotten away with having him
have arms and then when he says he
didn't have arms people would believe it
the big problem would be it would be the
hoopla of continuity error and oh no no
but but Finn and Jake he's a spirit
animal and of course it's like he's not
an animal so I think I understand what
you're saying where you're coming from
but I think most people would just be
like that's a con una Tierra I bago work
but yeah so so it's actually Marceline's
old boyfriend as who wanted her to get
rid of the memory of them breaking up so
Finn and Jake do that and he goes out
with her again and he's still kind of a
jerk and then makes her remember the
memory and they just kick the crap out
of him pretty much Oh mostly in the ball
yeah oh and while they're in Finn's
memory there's a dance that handsome yep
punching a buns in it good thing you're
not a witch that's awesome just deal
with it
I guess I have to they made a frigging
book out of it go buy it by the way
that's the way but yeah you just
probably gonna like take this on just
you guys singing that roller they're
gonna be like girls we're not gonna let
you post this out
I bet we've mostly been quiet about that
but if it's like everybody it's
like the biggest ass had all the
videogame companies and music companies
and stuff it's like we're not even
saying anything just YouTube's doing
this whatever France episode oh I guess
just that Martina had a boyfriend and he
was a jerk and nothing else hi all right
we break it down to I guess it's if
there are hints of stuff like you saw
you saw a little bit for childhood which
was kind of interesting you saw a
destroyed tank in the bed which I liked
you know again just signifying sort of
the war that blew up everything um I
like it whenever they have a kid
character that's a young representation
of and all the character an adult
character when they actually get a kid
to do the voice I just think that's more
fun I like what they did with baby
plucky enjoy you do what they have to
got a kid to do it you know it's like I
just love it when they really do that um
though I'm assuming that was Finn doing
baby Finn and that was pretty funny I
don't know possibly I actually though
even then the more thing about if I
would have been funnier they got like a
really younger killing actually could be
even funnier punch of your buns so yeah
I'm going to the credits to see um but
yeah so so pretty much uh CC her as a
kid I loved it once she says I hurt you
because I love you right that's nice and
messed up um you see the father
eating the fries which it still not
really explained why she would ever
heartbroken she's a teenager everything
a parent does to a teenager is like
daggers daggers how
was your day oh my god no no it's like I
get I get that no I understand that but
I think there's still other that's
directly how they're playing it off like
there's I think they just want something
really silly and stupid but not
necessarily like it's because she's a
teen she's like that um maybe bit just
plays I hit it I don't know I get the
feeling there's more of a story behind
that
like once you find out like the
importance of the fries or something
maybe it's the one thing she isn't read
maybe I mean yeah like that would say
yeah it just feels like there'd be
something else bigger thing going on I
get the feeling they probably hinted at
it but I don't know um so yeah well it's
affected the father like what he was
told at one time was like you know
marcelina so sorry I didn't know like
it's not like oh you're just being a
dumb teen like he's like wow I never
realized that so there's some weight to
it and I am curious about that it's like
the one thing I'm the most curious maybe
even more them be a whole apocalypse
thing is just what is the Frye's thing
and when you see it it's like well it
really answer anything still but it's
like I'm still curious like if there's a
story to that
so what else what else we have like one
thing was all like watching that scene
and he's like well when you have little
Marceline little Mars or when you have a
little Marcy playing with her little
bear
Lea do mercy which that's the bear that
is her most prized possession remember
he sold it and she's like that's the
most important thing to me and that's
why they broke up so you see she has it
as a kid which it looks like to me at
least was right after the mushroom war
because they're still fired he in in the
background and everything but what's one
thing about a little Marcy that's
different than the other times they show
her throughout no thanks
no no bite marks no bite marks so so she
was probably one of the survivors of the
mushroom or what
you know and it's yeah cuz that's why
I'll say cuz like there's nobody else
around and she had the bear the bear
looked like it'd been through hell and
she keeps and it has patches since to be
when she needs a new eye she takes one
of her button so you get the idea she's
taking like bits of her clothes or where
she can find and she's trying to keep
this thing alive cuz that's probably all
she has yeah maybe the fries for like
the other best friends yeah yeah your
childhood friend or something like maybe
a little older and probably more moldy
and let's say McDonald's fries in which
case yeah they still be they just be
like a different color and that's it and
then you ask the question last episode
or every other episode about Finn and
Jake remember when there's the little
dance
Marceline laughs and she's in this
hallway that has a bunch of pictures of
I didn't see what the pictures were oh
no no I didn't oh my god their parents
Jake's parent Oh Jake and Finn
specifically says this is the house I
grew up and this is okay so it so it
probably is that Jake's family raised in
them yes okay you kissed a boom-boom
baby so there's so much going on in this
friggin world you know it's it's tough
but it's you know I picked up on the tag
I picked up that she was a vampire and
the bad could got a few things but no I
actually but no I was trying to pay
attention to a little bit of
surroundings with him as a youngin cuz
it's like a lease to the q-dance I'm
like wait a minute this is it this is
the past let me look around it's because
it's yeah I really do like that I like
how it's something that an older
audience would really want to look for
it but younger on it just one thing up
and they don't really draw attention to
every younger kids that really is
something fun for adults to observe um
and it's a dumb Murray climber comes on
trying to get all I think the only thing
they have is the quote-unquote mushroom
wars which could just be you know to a
kid just could be mushrooms you know you
don't know and everything else is just
so slight
into that mhm so yeah it is a
fascinating how there is sort of like
just this very you know terrifying
apocalyptic story going on that you
would just never figure out you know if
you were a little kid you're just so
curious okay like I say the apocalypse
happens okay how did all the other stuff
happen the magic world is that is what I
am so curious about well if it was
nuclear war like the mutations stuff
like that maybe I would Finn and
Marceline said well Marceline we don't
turn into a vampire but I mean how would
you know I don't know maybe remember
there was uh oh my god what was her name
from below listen to yeah that's right
they were on the ground and stuff yeah
and we don't know if there's or not but
it seems like she could be so maybe yeah
they get that okay you know yeah I take
it back that's sort of the closest one
we've had to really say hey Finn is like
the only human is there another human
and that one actually did bring that to
the forefront the like even a kid would
be like yeah we're the humans or is she
what's you to make human to how that
work um so ya know it's uh I like this
one end at first I was sort of like oh I
thought there's gonna be even more cuz
anything like going into the mind of
something if it that's your time I'm
like holy crap I got a little I get
ready for this and I really like the
scene where they're in silhouette or
white solid I should say and they're
trying to look for the memory and I
thought that was very cool looking you
know everything else are like you know
okay yeah John Malkovich be John
Malkovich did that and let's kinda need
the gravity thing but I thought it's
gonna be a lot more surreal / maybe more
the forefront dramatic but yeah I like
how more in the background you know if
you're sort of observing a lot of that
stuff you can pick up on it uh but it's
not like there's nothing in the for
ground yeah
well that was very obviously in the for
yes I picked up on that but not the
pictures and no I just love how they
show her picking her nose and which is
wiping it on the couch there
thing just like through like the little
like window thing if you will just going
this way I love how his face is just
like I do like the varying sizes - I
thought that was so nice so ten thousand
where Alice in Wonderland but yeah both
of those I thought it it still worked I
still like you're still an effective way
of going for no other curiosities that
I'm very curious like five six years
from now are you gonna sit there and say
that's very adventure tiny I think you
should oh you know this stuff is doing a
lot of things there's like like anything
like it William beams out Malkovich
takes from my mouth when I land to it
and like Frank inside all these famous
if you'd ever use that I'm sure I'm sure
well because I mean it has created its
own very unique world that's borrowing
from other stuff but is so its own thing
yeah and has so much energy and
unpredictability which I like and but
you don't like to punch your book so and
not for the buildup
hmm I'm settling in this time
Oh